Гість програми сьогодні - Володимир Кличко.
Дякую за інтерв'ю.
Минулого року ви вирішили завершити свою спортивну кар'єру і сказали, я цитую:
"Ніколи не кажи ніколи".
Ви збираєтеся повертатися на боксерський ринг?
Я мав рацію, коли сказав це.
Ніколи не кажи ніколи, адже все може змінитися.
Я справді сказав, що завершую спортивну кар'єру і переключаюсь на інше.
Але люди можуть змінювати сфери діяльності багато разів протягом життя.
Подивіться на Арнольда Шварценеґґера.
Він був спортсменом, потім став актором, потім політиком.
З політики перейшов у бізнес, а зараз він займається екологічними проблемами.
Це його останнє заняття в житті, чи він повернеться до акторства?
Якщо я і вийду зараз на ринг, то лише заради благодійної мети.
Але з професійного боксу Ви пішли?
Останні 27 років я займався спортом, і це були чудові часи.
Я багато їздив по світу і багато чому навчився.
Думаю, що за ці 27 років у спорті я домігся того, про що і мріяти не міг.
Я займався тим, про що навіть не міг подумати.
Багато дверей зачинилися, але багато з них відчинилися для мене.
Насправді я щасливий, бо обрав саме цей шлях, а не став лікарем.
Замість того, щоб лікувати людей, я, по суті, відправляв цих людей до лікарів.
І сам теж в якийсь момент опинявся після боїв у лікарні.
Але це все життєвий досвід, і спорт - це щось неймовірне.
Я наведу висловлювання Нельсона Мандели:
"Спорт може змінити світ, тому що він - глобальний".
Зараз ви самі намагаєтеся змінити світ:
після закінчення професійної спортивної кар'єри створюєте щось нове.
Чим Ви зараз займаєтесь?
Ми зараз перебуваємо у Києві, в офісі "Фонду Кличко".
Він вже шістнадцятий рік поспіль реалізує різноманітні проекти.
За час існування Фонду в його програмах взяли участь близько півмільйона дітей.
Наш фокус - спорт та освіта.
Ми з Віталієм переконані, що це правильний шлях.
Ви знаєте, коли я перебуваю тут, у цьому місці,
мені приємно усвідомлювати, що крім іншої нашої діяльності,
ми робимо щось гарне для майбутнього дітей.
Хто я насправді? Чи можу я себе вважати у деякій мірі філантропом?
Можливо. З іншого боку, я професійний спортсмен, і це теж правда.
Я сам довго розмірковував над тим, хто я насправді.
Ким я став після завершення професійної кар'єри у спорті?
Чим я займаюсь? Чи став я бізнесменом? Не зовсім, але все ж так.
У якийсь момент я підібрав правильні слова, щоб позначити, чим я зараз займаюся.
Я людина, яка допомагає іншим розкривати свій потенціал.
І роблю я це з пристрастю.
Думаю, Ви добре знаєте про поширене ставлення до спортсменів, і боксери не виняток у цьому випадку.
Так от, у свідомості багатьох, спортсмени не відрізняються інтелектом.
Ви хочете зламати цей стереотип?
Ви правильно сказали: це стереотип. І стереотипи є скрізь.
Вважається, що всіх журналістів можна купити, всі політики брешуть.
Всі спортсмени ідіоти, всі тенісистки - лесбіянки, а всі співаки - гомосексуалісти.
Так, існує стереотипне мислення, коли людям певного роду занять приписують певні риси.
У 2016 році Ви запустили освітню програму під власним брендом
в університеті міста Санкт-Ґаллен у Швейцарії. Яка її мета?
Кожен з нас стикається з життєвими труднощами, проблеми вводять нас у ступор.
Число викликів множиться, адже світ прискорюється, ускладнюється,
тому що стає глобальним.
У величезному потоці новин складно відрізняти правду від так званих фейків.
Адже кожен з нас ще повинен зрозуміти, де істина, а де брехня.
Орієнтуватися в цьому складно.
І ми повинні змінити наші підходи пропорційно новим викликам.
Зокрема, викликам цифрової революції, яка докорінно змінила все,
що відбувалося і працювало 10 або 20 років тому.
У зв'язку з цим є запит на експертизу щодо того, як долати ці виклики.
Є запит на так званий челлендж-менеджмент або управління викликами.
Це те, в чому я маю досвід як спортсмен з 27-річним стажем -
як на боксерському ринзі, так і за його межами.
І ця програма у швейцарському університеті Санкт-Ґаллена
саме заснована на моєму практичному досвіді у цій сфері.
Тепер на основі мого емпіричного досвіду два дослідники займаються створенням
науково обґрунтованої теорії і збираються по цій темі захищати свої докторські дисертації.
Це однорічна чи дворічна програма?
Це шестимісячна програма.
Скільки це коштує?
15 тисяч євро.
Якщо ви хочете отримати додаткову освіту,
ви повинні відкладати на це гроші та витрачати їх на ці цілі.
Ви часто вживаєте слово "виклик", і я навіть розумію, з чим це пов'язано.
Ваша нова книга так і називається "Управління викликами".
Вона була надрукована німецькою мовою і тепер перекладена на англійську.
В цій книзі Ви стверджуєте, що коли Ви починали свою професійну кар'єру,
імідж боксу як спорту в Німеччині був вкрай негативним.
Чому було таке ставлення?
Я вважаю, що необхідно впроваджувати цифрові технології, які забезпечать прозорість.
Прозорість - кращий засіб для розв'язання проблеми,
адже вона знизить бюрократію і все спростить.
Якщо говорити про корупцію, то цифрові технології - найефективніший інструмент боротьби з нею.
Якщо говорити про бокс, то я переконаний,
що фанатам має бути надано право голосу у виборі суддів.
Тобто, корупція в боксі існує і в Німеччині?
Бокс - це міжнародний вид спорту, й існують різні організації по всьому світу.
Є федерації, є величезна кількість людей, залучених у бокс тим чи іншим способом.
Тобто, принцип "розділяй і володарюй" діє не лише у застосуванні щодо суспільства, але і щодо спорту.
У випадку з боксом існує аматорський і професійний бокс, і ці дві групи борються одна з одною.
Я не вважаю це правильним.
Я дуже радий, що під час останніх Олімпійських ігор
вперше в історії боксери - і любителі, і професіонали - були разом.
Була синергія, хоча низка людей сприйняли це критично.
Вони казали: та як це можна, що професійний боксер
бере участь у бою проти мого сина або дочки?!
Але мені здається, що це і було здорово!
Очевидно, що до спортсменів ставляться з величезним пієтетом,
набагато більшим, ніж, наприклад, до політиків. Чому це так?
Ну, по-перше завдяки величезній кількості уболівальників.
Звичайно, у політиків теж є певна база підтримки,
вона залежить від того, який політичний спектр представляє той чи інший політик.
Але у спортсменів ця база значно ширша, ніж у політиків.
Спортсмени притягують своїми виступами,
вони завойовують серця вболівальників, навіть якщо вони мають іншу культуру.
Я і Віталій змогли цього досягти у Німеччині, незважаючи на те, що ми не німці,
ми говоримо німецькою з акцентом, хоча висловлюємось цілком зрозуміло.
Коли я стою на паспортному контролі і даю свій український паспорт, прикордонник запитує:
"Як так? Я думав, у вас німецьке громадянство".
І я відповідаю, що у мене ніколи не було німецького громадянства.
І також у США, в інших країнах. У спорті ці речі не мають значення.
Ви постійно говорите про свого старшого брата Віталія,
я кілька разів брала у нього інтерв'ю.
Він зараз мер Києва.
Ви підтримуєте брата в його прагненні займатися політикою в Україні?
Я підтримую свого брата останні 42 роки.
Він відмінний хлопець.
І він стикається з такими викликами, з якими мало хто міг би впоратися.
У нього немає спеціальної освіти для політичної кар'єри,
він вчиться всьому на практиці, і це нормально.
Не варто думати стереотипами і намагатися загнати в ці стереотипні рамки інших людей.
У спорті теж є безліч викликів, але там існують правила гри, а в політиці їх немає.
Так, формально вони є, але фактично все вирішується кулуарно.
На жаль, це не так, як в боксі, де вам просто можуть розбити ніс або поставити синяк під оком.
У політиці ж наслідки можуть бути куди більш серйозними.
І Ви знаєте це як ніхто інший.
Політика - це дуже серйозний виклик, і я знаю, наскільки Віталію непросто.
Але він може ще вдосконалюватися.
Головне, що, як на мене, у нього прогресивні погляди.
Ви, напевно, знаєте, що Вашого брата часто висміюють.
Які почуття у Вас це викликає, коли Ви бачите це в інтернеті?
Ви знаєте, це як з погодою.
Якщо взимку ходити у футболці та шортах, можна змерзнути.
До цього потрібно бути добре підготовленим,
якщо займаєшся політикою, потрібно бути готовим і до критики, і, звичайно ж, до насмішок.
Треба бути товстошкірим, інакше не варто займатися політикою.
Якщо чесно, я взагалі не сприймаю брата як політика.
Російсько-українські відносини драматично погіршилися після анексії Криму.
Чи були у Вас коли-небудь суперечки з вашими колегами-спортсменами з Росії з цього приводу?
Як на Вас це все вплинуло?
Життя кидає багато викликів.
На сьогоднішній день у принципі не можна говорити про будь-які відносини між Росією та Україною.
Вони неймовірно погіршилися через розбіжності в інтересах, різні уявлення про життя й очікування.
А в підсумку щодня гинуть люди,
українську землю топчуть чоботи іноземних солдатів і військова техніка.
Те, що відбувається, це реалізація в політиці принципу "розділяй і володарюй",
хоча в даному випадку доречніше буде сказати "розділяй і завойовуй".
Спортсмени кажуть, що не можна звинувачувати повністю всю країну.
Не можна говорити, що всі росіяни погані.
Не всі. Як можна говорити, що всі українці погані?
Але я хочу сказати, що я оптиміст, я не сприймаю світ винятково у темних тонах.
Історія розвивається, повторюються і погані періоди, і гарні.
Я сподіваюся, що конфлікт між Росією та Україною буде зрештою розв'язаний.
Студенти ставлять Вас перед викликами. Я теж придумала для Вас одне завдання.
Я прочитала у Вашій книзі, що в дитинстві Ви займалися брейк-дансом,
але гроші для цього, які дала Вам Ваша мама,
Ви програли в ігрових автоматах, тож Ви навчилися самотужки.
Можете зараз станцювати?
Я зроблю лише один рух.
Два рухи?
Жанно, ти можеш танцювати?
Чому ні? Давай потанцюємо!